(soft violin ensemble begins)
(soft violin music continues)
- Before we start I wanted
to thank the musicians
from The Yale School of Music.
There you are,
I wish we could do this...
(audience applauding)
I wish we could do this
at every press conference,
I'm not sure if you're available.
We also have some over
at the police station.
Dean Blocker, I think you
were gonna come up and say,
there you are,
a few words about your program.
- Thank you.
Thank you Mayor Elicker,
and President Salovey.
Our quartet today,
represents many, many,
many groups from Yale
that participate in the community.
I can say for this quartet,
and for many others,
that they learn as much from
working in the community,
as they give.
And that's the great
magic of what we do here.
For those of us who lived
here for a long time,
but for our students who live
here for four or five years.
The Music in Schools Program at Yale,
with which these ladies are affiliated,
serves around 1200 students
in the public schools.
And these young artists have soloed with
the New York Phil, the Seoul
Phil, all around the world.
Can you imagine being a 10-year-old,
and studying with one of them?
But, what they would tell
you is they're enriched
by the lives of these young
people that they work with,
and that we work with in this community.
So, Mayor Elicker, and
those of you who are
representing the New Haven
organizations that host us,
and help us enable these interactions
where we not only can bring hope,
but receive hope, we thank you.
And we look forward to the years ahead,
where these programs grow,
and are enriched.
And I want to especially
thank Christina Lear,
our cellist, Rihanna Heath, the violist,
and Kate Art, and Anna Lee, our violinist.
It's a great privilege to be here,
and to open up this momentous occasion.
Thank you, Mr. Mayor.
(group applauding)
- Thank you.
And before we start, some remarks.
Wanted to make some acknowledgments,
and I'm gonna try to do this with my eyes,
just looking around the room,
I see Adler Furlow, I see Alder Sabin,
Alder DeCola,
of course, President Walker-Myers is here.
Other Alders?
Alder Marks, good to see Alder Marks.
Any other Alders?
Senator Martin Looney is here.
State Representatives, or State
Senators, good to see you.
I also noticed Dr. Brown,
Dr. Brown, from Gateway,
Dr. Bertolino from Southern.
And Garrett is here from the Chamber.
Will, from the Greater New
Haven Community Foundation.
I believe Dr. Camille,
may be here, as well.
Many other people.
I also like to thank all
of the people that are,
and acknowledge your presence,
that will call me later on,
telling me that I forgot to
acknowledge your presence.
(group laughing)
Today's a historic moment.
It's a historic moment.
This is a really big deal.
Today, Yale President, Peter Salovey,
Board of Alders President,
Tyisha Walker-Myers,
and I, are announcing
a historic commitment
between Yale University
and the City of New Haven.
That will see the University contribute
an additional $52 million
in voluntary payments
to the City of New Haven
over the next six years.
And, partner with the
City in an effort to build
a more equitable New Haven for all.
This is the most significant commitment
that Yale University has
ever made to the City.
And, I'm grateful for Peter Salovey.
Your partnership, and
your team's partnership
in making this happen.
I'd like to turn it over to you
to make some remarks, thanks.
- Thank you.
(group applauding)
- Well, thank you, Mayor Elicker,
I appreciate those warm remarks.
And it is so wonderful to see
so many of you here today.
I won't try to acknowledge
everybody, just a few.
First of all, I'm delighted
to be here with you, Mayor.
And the Board of Alders,
particularly, President
Tyisha Walker-Myers.
State Senate President, Martin Looney.
And so many neighbors and
friends with us today.
Just one shout out,
and that is a special
friend, Henry Fernandez.
Who really helped shepherd this day,
this agreement forward, and
really appreciate your work.
(group applauding)
Obviously, my home team,
I thank them every day,
for the hard work and
partnership that they provide
at Yale University.
So, I'm a long-time resident of this city.
41 years this year.
And I've been faculty member
for about 36 years of those 41.
And I'm just deeply grateful,
that today we can be together
to honor, and deepen,
Yale's strong, enduring relationship
with the City of New Haven.
The new commitments that
we're announcing today,
are, been formed by
decades of collaboration
between members of Yale, and
the New Haven communities.
And it's particularly
meaningful that we are
launching these new
initiatives as we prepare
to emerge from a pandemic.
At this critical inflection point,
Yale and New Haven are
making an empathic statement.
Making an empathic
statement about our bond.
We're choosing to work
together to make the most
of this remarkable moment
in the City's history.
Like never before, New Haven
is poised for accelerated
expansion and inclusive growth.
The population is growing,
along with the City's promising innovation
and economic infrastructure.
From new developments,
such as 101 College Street,
to flourishing residential, commercial,
and research spaces.
Our city is entering a new era.
An era that I haven't
seen in my 41 years here.
And, I'm grateful to the Governor,
for the state's role in
encouraging and supporting
private investment here in New Haven,
projects like 101 College Street.
We have an extraordinary
opportunity to position New Haven
for sustained, inclusive development
across every neighborhood.
So as an anchor institution,
and the City's largest employer,
Yale is proud.
Proud to join New Haven, and
the State of Connecticut,
increasing investments in our home city.
First, Yale is extending it's lead,
as the institution that makes the largest
annual voluntarily contribution
of any U.S. college,
or university, to it's home city.
We're increasing Yale's
voluntary contribution,
as you heard, to New Haven, by 52 million
over the next six years,
$52 million over the next six years.
This equates to over $135 million
in our total voluntary payments
to support, for example,
our libraries, the
education of our children,
and many vital city services.
Combined with funding from
the state's new Pilot Program,
continued contributions
by the private sector.
Federal support,
will make tremendous, positive
difference in this city.
Mentioning Pilot,
let me take a moment to
thank Senator Looney,
for his vision and creativity,
in re-thinking the Pilot
Program in a way...
(group applauding)
that has greater impact for New Haven.
So in addition to the increase
in our voluntary payment,
Yale will also gradually offset the loss
in tax revenues,
if the University should take
properties off the tax roll,
to create facilities for
teaching and research.
We have an innovated strategy
that will allow Yale to
provide long-term benefits,
both to the University, and the City,
through our growth,
while ensuring that New
Haven does not lose out
on tax revenue in the short term.
Although our financial
support is important,
Yale is committing more
than just dollars today.
We've all seen how
American cities have faced
a host of challenges.
Many of which were exasperated
by the COVID pandemic.
So, we're establishing a new
center for inclusive growth
to help address these problems.
The center will examine,
develop, and implement
new strategies for
growing the City's economy
to the benefit of all New Haven residents.
It will compliment work that is being done
by the Community Foundation
for Greater New Haven,
by Conn Corps, Next Haven,
COLAB,
Black Business Alliance,
New Haven Innovation Collaborative,
and many other organizations
concerned about this challenge.
So, I've asked Professor Kerwin Charles,
the Indra K. Nooyi Dean of
the Yale School of Management,
to launch this effort,
and he is with us today.
There he is in the back.
(group applauding)
So he'll have the help
of an advisory committee
of University, city,
and community leaders.
And we will bring together
Yale's scholarly strengths
to bear on issues at our front door,
at our city's front door.
The Center for Inclusive
Growth will demonstrate
the power of our partnership
with New Haven in action.
So of course, the center will be opening
in a city that has been undergoing
a wonderful renaissance.
Over the years, artistic,
cultural, and dining
destinations have emerged
across our city,
generating economic development,
inviting more people to
discover our vibrant community.
So, I'm delighted that
another element of our plan,
our partnership together,
creates a new public space,
where friends and neighbors can gather.
By converting High Street,
between Chapel and Elm Streets,
into a pedestrian walkway,
free of vehicle access,
will foster an attractive social hub
near iconic and city landmarks
that everyone can enjoy.
Just to be clear, the City will
continue to own the street.
Yale will redevelop and design this space,
and fund the renovation of
it, into a pedestrian mall.
So the new innovations, I'm sorry,
the new investments we're launching,
represent a major step forward
in Yale's enduring
commitment to New Haven.
At the same time,
we will continue to support an array
of existing Yale programs,
expected to total over an
additional $100 million
in contributions over the next six years.
So for example, New Haven Promise,
which provides scholarships for the City's
public school students to attend
any university in Connecticut,
will continue to be an
investment focus for Yale.
The Yale University Home Buyer Program,
that helps our employees
purchase homes in the City,
will continue to be supported.
New Haven Works, which offers
job training, and placement,
and other services,
continues to be a focus.
Each of these initiatives,
including contributions to
the Downtown Business
Improvement District,
cultural events, and other local causes,
helps create a stronger,
and more resilient community together.
Community where we all can live,
where we all can work,
where we can feel that partnership between
the University and the City, itself.
I believe that our actions can exemplify
how institutions of higher education
can continue to partner
with their home cities
to serve the common good.
And I hope we serve as
an inspiration to others.
I'm so grateful to join
you, join all of you.
Particularly Mayor Elicker,
in writing the next chapter in Yale,
and New Haven's shared history.
And I can't wait to get to work on all
that lays ahead of us.
Hand-in-hand,
we will create an exciting,
and prosperous future
for everyone here,
for everyone in our city,
and for those who will come after us.
Thank you all for being here.
Mayor Elicker, thank you for your support.
(group applauding)
Thank you.
- Thank you, Peter, for your partnership.
And your leadership and commitment
to the City of New Haven.
Peter and I have gotten to know each other
quite well over the past two years.
And to think back on our first meeting,
and how far we've come,
in our trust for each other,
but, I think more importantly,
the representation of the University
and the City's trust in collaboration,
is a testament to you,
you and your team's willingness
to really work hard to get
this across the finish line.
- Thank you, Mayor, and
absolutely feel the same way
about you and your team.
- Thank you.
I'd also like to thank both teams
that have made this possible.
To the Yale team,
you have worked tirelessly
to come to the table with openness,
and honesty.
And to our city team,
Michael Gormany, Kevin Alvarez,
Shawn Madison, Sue Weisselberg,
a volunteer.
Mike Piscitelli,
thank you for expanding
your work to include
this very important project.
And to Henry,
the lead on the City's team.
Who has volunteered hours, and hours,
of your time, your wisdom, your expertise,
over this past year.
Thank you for what you helped
us all accomplish together.
I spoke with Peter last night,
and we both felt that
it was very important
to acknowledge the work
that you have done,
and to ask you to share
some words with all of us.
Henry?
(group applauding)
- Thank you, thank you, Mayor.
My family thanks you as well,
for our being able to get
their husband, and dad, back.
After a year of this effort.
But it was wonderful.
I do wanna give,
I wanna echo what the
mayor said about the teams
on both sides, here.
It was wonderful to work with all you.
But I wanna give a special thanks
to Jack Callahan, from Yale,
who is a son of New Haven,
and an honest negotiating
partner on the other side.
Thank you, Jack.
(group applauding)
So, I wanna start by just talking
a little bit about what we did.
So, we spent time understanding
each other's positions.
It was apparent that over the years,
as people changed in offices,
and new actors emerged,
both relationships, and understandings,
between the University and
the City, weren't present.
I don't mean that everyone become friends
through this process,
and that certainly was not our goal.
But we were able to explain our positions
and understand each other's
goals and interests.
I think Yale came to understand
that New Haven was addressing
structural problems,
inherent in how state law treats cities,
and taxes city residents.
The City's team came to
understand how Yale sees it growth
and how it is balancing competing demands
within it's own institution.
We spent some time as a group,
also discussing issues that are far bigger
than either the City, or the University.
These issues include
matters of racial justice,
and economic disparity that
have built up over centuries,
in our city, and our country.
And the recent ramifications
of these issues
in the context of COVID-19,
climate change,
and the protest movements around policing,
across the country, and the globe.
And while these issues are bigger
than any one of us,
or either the City, or the university,
that doesn't mean that
we can ignore history.
Or that we can ignore equity,
or the disparities that are obvious
for all of us in our city.
As President Salovey mentioned,
we saw to tackle three significant issues.
First, is the amount of funding
that goes from the University to the City
in voluntary payments.
I just wanna be really clear
about what we're talking about.
In the first year,
over $23 million will
go from the University,
to the City.
It will go up every year,
over the course of five years.
And then it will drop in year six,
which I suggest to the Mayor,
would be a good time to start negotiating
before you get there.
(group chuckling)
Sorry!
Now that we're done.
(group laughing)
There's a big red light in year six.
Pay attention to it.
As a result of this agreement,
Yale now contributes more
than any other university
to it's hometown.
In the past, different
universities could quibble
about whether they were paying more,
or how to count one kind
of payment structure
over another.
There is no longer
anything to quibble about.
Yale's annual contributions
do not have anything close to them.
I firmly believe, however,
that other universities should see this
as the new standard.
We are in the midst of a global pandemic,
in a time of great economic disparity.
Where anti-democratic forces
use these tragedies to try to divide us.
In this moment, other
well-known universities
around the country, can
only truly be great,
if they try to beat what we have done,
and reset again the standard.
But for today,
I feel good about the new
standard that we have set.
Second, is the issue
of taxable properties.
Connecticut cities have
historically relied on
property taxes to pay their bills.
Indeed, it has been the only
major tool that they control.
This has created a
negative town down dynamic,
between New Haven and Yale,
basically forever.
Because of the hard
work of Senator Looney,
and the entire New Haven delegation,
Tiered Pilot is now a reality.
This new relationship
between the City and Yale
is possible, in part,
because of Tiered Pilot.
Specifically, Yale will
make payments to the City
for any properties taken off the tax rolls
at the full amount for three years,
and then, in declining
amounts for another 10 years.
Because of the combination of Pilot,
and Yale's commitment,
the City will now be whole,
for years after any conversion
of property to tax exempt.
That takes care of the
short and medium-term.
And in the long term,
we believe that growth at the University,
for instance, in the sciences,
will help create tax-paying
buildings for businesses,
and good-paying jobs.
Third, we recognize
the issues of disparity
that I mentioned earlier.
To tackle these,
the University, and the
City, will work together
at The Center for Inclusive Growth.
And as, the President and Mayor,
what the President said,
and the Mayor will say,
I'm excited for the leadership
of Dean Kerwin Charles.
This center will not
simply study the problems.
But instead, will use best research
to facilitate the City and
the University's work together
to address real issues
in our neighborhoods.
Those issues that effect
low-income people,
African-Americans, Latinos,
immigrants and refugees
in our community the most.
Including, climate change,
access to high-speed internet.
And if we recall over the last 18 months,
we saw the lack of high-speed internet
play out with our school
children dramatically.
Also, jobs, affordable housing,
and a myriad of other needs.
The simple idea is that
we can build a city,
and the people,
the simple idea,
is that we can build a city that grows
and benefits both Yale University,
in the center of our community,
and the people across the
City of all backgrounds,
in all neighborhoods, who love
the City and call it home.
In five or six years,
the City and Yale can re-evaluate.
We probably got some things right.
And may have gotten some things wrong.
They may need to be more
aggressive in some areas,
and back off in others.
Now, I do wanna say a
word about the street.
About High Street.
Certainly Yale is interested
in having High Street
operate as no longer a street for cars.
But we agreed early-on that
we would do so differently,
than done previously.
High Street will remain
a public thoroughfare.
Legally owned by the City of New Haven.
Yales will design it, in
consultation with the City,
specifically to ensure that is
a place for all New Haveners.
Whether walking, or on bicycles,
whether studying at Yale, or at Hillhouse.
We look forward to a
beautiful new destination
that welcomes all of us,
and guests from around the world.
Finally, having volunteered for this role,
I ask only in return, that
the City and the University,
see this agreement as a starting point.
It can be the first step in a
new way of working together.
Or, we can see it as a
series of transactions.
It is, I believe, a fair
set of transactions.
And in five years,
the parties will need to get
together to negotiate again.
But my hope is that we assembled,
what we assembled here,
shows that we can do much
bigger things together.
That we can work together
to ensure that Tiered
Pilot stays in place,
and support Senator Looney in that.
That we can do large, renewable
energy projects together,
that make New Haven a
center of what's possible.
That Yales students, and
students at Wexler Grant,
can have ridiculously fast internet,
and all of the opportunities
that come with that.
Because we can work together
to cover our downtown,
and our neighborhoods with fiber optics.
That we set new standards for growth
that focus on good-paying jobs,
and allow our residents to
benefit equally from that growth.
That we'll be aggressive in
re-building neighborhoods.
And if we are able to tackle
these bigger things together,
we can all rejoice when a new
building is built at Yale.
Just as much as we can rejoice,
when more affordable housing is built
in one our new residential high-rises,
or one of our neighborhoods.
Because cities are great only
when they benefit us all.
Our city will be great when we
all look out for each other.
And then, and when, those
with power and opportunity
use it to make our city
more equal and just.
With that, I'd like to say
thank you to the Mayor.
I'll turn over the keys, you
can drive the car, I'm done.
(group laughing)
But thank you, thank
you for the opportunity.
(group applauding)
- Thank you again, Henry.
This is real win for New Haven.
The New Haven community,
and it's a win for Yale University.
Because what's good for New
Haven, is good for Yale.
For years, so many people have contributed
to making this moment a possibility.
New Haven Rising, Unite Here,
the Board of Alders, our state delegation,
faith leaders,
residents who have
attended public meetings,
people who have talked about it,
emailed about it, written about it,
posted on social media about it.
This moment is because of your work.
Without you, we would not be here today.
And President Salovey and Henry went over
the four points of the commitment.
And I wanna talk a little bit about
what these points actually
mean for the City and Yale.
First, the increase in voluntary payments
from the University will amount to,
over, as Peter said, $135
million over the next six years.
To put this in perspective,
Yale will be contributing to the City,
more over the next six years,
than it has in the past 20 years.
At a time when the City has been facing
significant financial challenges,
the University has now acknowledged
that we need to partner
together to address them.
Yale's increased contribution combined
with the increased Pilot payments,
championed by our state delegation,
and Senator Looney,
means that this fiscal year,
the City will have received
a total of 59 million
in additional contributions,
for over 10% of our overall budget.
That's truly remarkable.
And it's an acknowledgement
that all parties,
when we work together, can
accomplish incredible things.
Second, Yale's voluntary
offset of the loss
of tax revenues, when they take a property
off the tax rolls.
For years, Yale's growth
has taken taxable property
off the grand list,
putting pressure on the
City's budget, and taxpayers.
It's created a dynamic where many felt
that Yale's growth wasn't
benefiting our city.
This new, innovative approach,
better aligns the City,
and Yale's interest.
It means that Yale's
growth benefits our city,
not just through more jobs
and economic activity,
but also, by maintaining a tax revenue.
Now, when Yale grows, we all benefit.
Third, the block of High
Street, between Elm and Chapel.
In the past, the City
has sold public assets
to the University.
In this commitment, we
worked to accomplish the goal
of making the block of High Street safer
for Yale constituents,
and all community members,
in a way that ensures the
street remains a public asset
for all to enjoy.
Not only do we ensure
that property remains
in the public domain,
but together we set the right tone,
that Yale is a part of our community.
And finally, The Center
for Inclusive Growth.
While each component of the
commitment announced today,
is important,
I believe the creation of this center,
in particular,
meets this moment in time, in history.
When we started the
conversation with Yale,
it wasn't just about writing a check.
It was about how we work together
to change our city,
so that opportunities experienced by some
in our community,
could be experienced by all.
This is a challenge our
world is struggling with.
And Yale has decided to do this work
in it's own backyard.
In it's home, New Haven.
Yale's enthusiasm for the Center,
is key to it's success.
President Salovey has been serious,
not just about this in words,
but in who he has asked to take it on,
with Dean Charles, who
has specific expertise
in inter-generational
transmission of economic status,
and wealth inequality.
Did I get that right?
Mostly? Mostly?
(group chuckling)
And the fact that Yale is contributing
an additional $5 million
to help start the Center.
We all know that New Haven is growing.
And while our team at the City,
works very hard to ensure
that growth is equitable,
still there is much work ahead of us,
so the communities, particularly
the communities of color,
who have historically
been under-resourced,
will benefit from this growth.
The Center for Inclusive
Growth will set the tone
that the University and
the City work together
to ensure that everyone in New Haven
has the opportunity to thrive.
There are vast opportunities here,
for harnessing both the real,
and intellectual capital
of the University through the Center,
and expanding it's impact
through partnerships
with the Community Foundation
for Greater New Haven,
other local colleges and universities,
and other partners in the region.
Taking together today's commitments
fundamentally reset the relationship
between Yale and the City of New Haven.
And they put the City on
a more sustainable financial path.
And they acknowledge that
the University and city,
and committing to ensuring that everyone
in our city has the opportunity to thrive.
This would not have been possible
without the partnership and
long work of years and years,
by President Tyisha Walker-Myers.
And I invite her now to speak.
(group applauding)
- Thank you, good afternoon.
I wanna thank the Mayor
and President Salovey,
and Mr. Fernandez, for laying
out the details of the deal,
because now I don't have to do that.
(group laughing)
But I think it's really
important that I'm here
to speak for the thousands of residents
that work with the unions
and elected officials
that brought awareness to the things
that we need in New Haven.
That never took their foot off the gas.
That continue to force the conversations.
And the greatest part of the
agreement, today, for me,
is that those residents finally,
finally have an opportunity to see that
Yale actually heard what they were saying.
This is a great start.
I'm looking forward to the partnership,
and the part of the partnership
where we're having the real conversations
about the things that our residents need.
I'm looking for the uncomfortable parts
of the conversations that will happen.
Because any time I'm involved,
that come up sometime.
About what our residents really need.
I'm looking forward to the
part of the conversation
where we actually have results about
bringing people in this
city out of poverty.
That's what I'm looking forward to.
Because I think that's really important.
And this agreement, it is
historic, as the Mayor said.
It's historic, because
we actually had unions,
elected officials,
and community members,
all working together,
over a number of years saying,
"Yale, please hear our cry."
We have needs that we
really need help addressing.
And Yale stepped up and said,
"We're hearing you, we're listening."
But a partnership is not over
once an agreement is signed.
It goes far beyond that.
So today is historic,
and I'm actually really
proud to stand here.
I don't come to many things
if I don't believe in it.
But anything that I'm involved in,
I won't take my foot off the gas.
I won't stop pressing the real issues.
I won't stop speaking for the residents
that felt like they never
had a voice up until now.
I'll continue doing that.
And I know that Yale hear,
you know, they hear that call.
I work with them in many
different capacities,
and I'm always the same way, I might add,
in all little spaces.
But for me, in order to
really be celebrating,
and we are celebrating,
because this is historic,
this is great for our city.
But the things that I really care about,
because I grew up here, too.
I am one of those
residents that felt like,
you get what you get from Yale,
and you can't get anything else.
So, I'm standing here
today for all those people
that didn't have faith
that a real partnership
was gonna happen.
So it's my responsibility
to make sure that happened.
And I won't stop, I just
wanna let yous know know.
It will get uncomfortable,
but we will get result.
Thank you.
(group applauding)
- I think there's a lot of us in this room
that can testify to that discomfort
that sometimes we feel
when talking to President Walker-Myers.
Dean Charles? Would you mind coming up
and saying a few words about the center?
(group applauding)
- I'm delighted to be here.
I am grateful to have been included
in the team on the Yale side.
And even more grateful,
that over the course of
the last several months,
we on the Yale side, and I
speak for myself, personally.
Have gotten a chance to
learn, to meet, to know,
to befriend our partners
on the New Haven side.
I say partners, because
it is my conviction,
and I believe the view of the Yale side,
if you call it that, more generally,
that Yale's thriving is tied
up with New Haven's success,
and vice-versa.
I'm stimulated by where
we have reached today,
the point we have reached.
During the course of
the last several months,
various things occurred to me.
I, for example, learned about activities
in which Yale is already engaged.
And has been engaged for many years,
scattered across the University.
We just saw the music program,
about which, I previously knew nothing.
Their similar opportunities,
or activities.
Whereas Yale has been
engaged in activities
in this university-wide fashion.
Any honest assessment of the City's needs,
in this historical moment,
made clear, it seems to me,
that there is opportunity and space.
Opportunity and space for activities
that foster inclusive growth.
What is meant by that term?
What is inclusive growth?
Obviously, there's a part of
it that has allowed growth.
By growth, I think, we jointly mean,
vibrant and robust, and
thriving economic activity.
Yes?
But I think, jointly,
we don't merely mean that.
We mean thriving, robust
economic activity,
that promotes health
and safety, for example.
The sustainable, for example.
Yes?
But even more than that,
the reason we include, as a group,
the inclusive piece, is that
we are jointly-committed
to the idea,
that such growth, as it
occurs in our community,
the benefits of that growth,
must be diffusely spread
across our community's neighborhoods,
our community's racial groups.
It must benefit whatever growth
occurs, all of New Haven.
So when I think about what we might do
on the inclusive growth side,
I think
there are multiple opportunities here
to enlarge upon, ongoing programs,
and to institute new ones.
Enlarge upon ongoing programs,
and implement new ones.
With the aim, guided by
the principle, I might say,
that whatever we,
new initiatives we start,
have the following features:
That they be truly collaborative,
truly collaborative.
That they be genuinely respectful.
Which is to say, that
whereas the Yale team might,
in a particular case, interact
with New Haven partners
on a particular problem,
we will not approach our conversation
with the presumption that
all the ideas rest on the Yale side.
Yes?
We believe there is much to be learned
from genuine collaboration.
Our collaboration must be respectful, yes?
And the hope is that it
would be mutually beneficial.
Both to Yale, and to New Haven.
The opportunities for this
kind of inclusive activity,
in my view, extend in
every department of Yale,
every school, every program.
I'm the Dean of the Yale
School of Management.
And I speak to you as the
representative of a single school.
Where other deans present,
I'm confident that each
of them could point
to some set of activities
ongoing, or contemplating, yes?
That would advanced the
ends I just described.
If I may take a moment
to speak about my school,
and how I envision where it sits
in the new center we are launching.
I believe that the Yale
School of Management
has an out-sized imperative,
and similarly, out-sized opportunity,
to profitably, and
meaningfully contribute,
in the way I just described.
Why this out-sized imperative
of what do I speak?
What do I mean by that?
Our imperative is out-sized,
and our opportunity is out-sized
because of the combination of
our peculiar distinctive mission
at the Yale School of Management.
The special expertise interest
and talents of our students,
and the research and scholarly
focus of our faculty.
A brief word about the mission.
The Yale School of Management is the only
business school in the country
that is organized, run
a mission that says,
"It seeks to train leaders
for business, and society."
It says.
"And society."
If that is truly our motto,
if that is truly our animating value,
let's begin by trying
to help this society.
The community in which we live.
Where our neighbors and
friends are every day.
Let's begin there, yes?
The special motto and set
of values of the school
is reflected in the kinds of students
who come to the school.
The kinds of students
Animated by,
not only a desire to be
successful business people,
but to transform the
world in a productive,
useful, and meaningful way
to benefit multiple stakeholders.
The Mayor knows a bit of whereof I speak.
Because some of our
students, and our graduates,
go on to do things like
become Mayor of their city.
(group laughing)
Talk to me.
Yeah? So the Mayor knows about that.
So we have mission.
We have the values of our students.
Those students also possess certain kinds
of human capital, expertise, and energy
that will benefit our city and community.
Our students can have internships here
at the City.
Our students can work on research projects
imagined by the City team.
Our students can engage and work with
non-profit organizations,
conversations that I have
already started as Dean.
On the research side,
some of the questions, the research ideas
that animate our faculty,
concern matters that are
interest to the City.
We have experts in any number of fields.
Operations,
finance,
accounting.
Who's ideas would be of value to our city,
as the growth we all imagine,
and hope for occurs in the coming years.
The non-profit sector.
Launching entrepreneur activity.
Social impact investing.
I can go on.
The precise details of all that will occur
under the umbrella of our new
initiative are not yet clear.
But I can assure you,
that I, and we, collectively,
embark upon that mission
with great enthusiasm.
And I personally have profound confidence,
that although we'll have
an uncomfortable
conversation here and there.
I'm cool with that.
(group laughing)
That our success is assured
if we bring to that effort,
the effort of collaboration,
friendship, openness,
and energy, will be brought
to our conversations
over the last year.
Thank you very much, Mayor.
(group applauding)
- So one of the speakers
stole my run of show,
but I'm pretty sure we are
at our last speaker here.
And when you think about
over this past two years,
what we've accomplished as
a city is quite remarkable.
Senator Looney, your leadership,
I always talk about how I sat down
at the Greek Olive with
you, just about two years,
and you said, "I have this idea."
This has dramatically benefited New Haven.
But, what we don't often
talk about in New Haven,
is how many other towns
and cities across our state
have received a significant increase
in the investment, because
of Senator Looney's work.
Those cities and towns are ones of need.
So the impact that you had
on our city is incredible,
with the impact on our state, as well.
So Senator Looney, maybe
you can finish us off here.
- Thank you, Mayor.
(group applauding)
- Thank you so much, Mayor.
This is truly a historic
day with this announcement
between the City of New
Haven, and Yale University.
I wanna congratulate Mayor Elicker,
President Salovey,
their negotiating teams,
certainly Dean Charles, Mr.
Callahan, on the Yale side.
Henry Fernandez, the visionary
leader on the City side.
Also like to give a shout
out to my dear friend
of 35 years, Sue Weisselberg,
who was on the City team.
And Sue...
(group applauding)
As many know...
A number of years ago,
she served as Council,
very effectively as Council
to our House Democratic Caucus
in the General Assembly,
and then, also directed the
school construction program
for the City of New Haven for many years,
which also, set a mark for the state,
in which a 1.5 billion program
to revolutionize New Haven's
physical plan of it's schools.
In which about 1.2 billion was paid
by the State of Connecticut,
in that partnership.
And her management of that
inspired great confidence.
But what we see here today
is, has been discussed,
is a new day.
And one of the things that
I think is most important,
early in the 2021 session,
President Salovey said
to me in a conversation,
if the State of Connecticut
is willing to enhance
it's commitment to the City of New Haven,
Yale will certainly respond
in kind, and do the same.
The State of Connecticut has done that.
And today, Yale announces
that it is also doing that.
And I think that that
is a meeting of promises
and commitments,
and aspirations on both sides.
President Salovey is
someone that I've know
and admired for a long time.
I think he has done a superb
job as Yale President.
We developed a close,
working relationship.
But years, in fact, a couple
of decades before that,
I worked closely as a board member,
the Fair Haven Community Health Center,
with his wife,
wonderfully public-spirited
and brilliant woman,
Marta Moret, so please
say hello to Marta for me.
And at the time, they lived
within the service area
of the Fair Haven Health Center.
The lived in Fair Haven.
So Peter Salovey knows
the view of New Haven
from elsewhere than Hillhouse Avenue.
Because he has lived that, too.
So, I wanted to thank him for that.
Again, the Pilot program that we were
able to reconfigure, in this session,
was something that had been
percolating for a while,
as Mayor Elicker and I strategized to bat,
a couple of years ago at the
Greek Olive, which is defunct,
but the program, of course, is not.
(group laughing)
And what it amounted to,
was a recognition that there are,
the Pilot needed a more
expanded constituency.
And the way to do that,
was to involve more towns
in Pilot eligibility.
And the approach that we found to do that,
was to look at equalized
net grand list per capita.
Now there are a large number
of relatively poor communities
in the state, notably
in Eastern Connecticut,
that are struggling,
even though they many not have
a lot of tax exempt property,
or Pilot-eligible property.
But, to the extent that they do,
if they have a net grand list per capita
of under $100,000, as of
course, all the major cities do,
they will get 50%
reimbursement under Pilot
for the tax-exempt college and hospital,
and also state property.
For those in the next tier,
between $100,000 and $200,000
of tax-exempt property,
those communities will get 40%.
And then, those over $200,000
and net grand list per
capita, will get 30%.
Now again, every tier is
above the current level
of reimbursement, which is about 25%.
So one of the reasons
we were able to develop
broad-based consensus on this,
that even the towns in the lowest tier,
were gonna get a significant increase
over what Pilot had been most recently.
So, we believe that this
will be transformative.
And coupled with the
increase in funding for Yale,
over the life of this program,
especially, Yale's commitment to continue
to pay taxes on properties newly taken off
the tax rolls for a period of time.
This is something that is going to result
in what we hoped it would do.
And I also wanna especially
thank my colleagues on this,
especially Representative Toni Walker,
of New Haven, who is, of course,
the House Chair of the General Assembly's
Appropriations Committee.
In that position, she was
critical in this enterprise.
And also, the Speaker of
the House, Matt Ritter,
who represents Hartford,
and his support for this,
of course, was critical.
And his city, of course,
is a major beneficiary
of the reconfigured Pilot, as well.
So again, I'm glad we were
able to come to this day.
I had confidence from the
very beginning that we would.
Because of the people involved,
and the honesty, and the earnestness,
and the solidity of their commitment.
So I think we have a great
deal to celebrate today.
Thank you, all.
(group applauding)